[Music]
yo what's up guys mkbhd here and welcome
to episode 5 of very very minor updates
by apple
so we got ipad pro earlier this year for
a minor update we had macbook air
earlier also a minor update we got
iphone se literally shares a bunch of
parts from a previous three-year-old
phone
so next up is this guy this is the newly
announced 2020 13-inch macbook pro
refresh so for a little context this
laptop 13-inch macbook pro has been my
go-to for a couple years now you know
the macbook air it's nice but it's a
little too lightweight it doesn't offer
all the performance that i want for
bigger things like photo editing and
then the bigger 16-inch macbook pro it's
more powerful yes but it's also a little
bigger than i want to carry around so
it's been like my go-to but for the past
five months i've been telling people do
not buy a 13-inch macbook pro that's
because once we saw the refresh of the
bigger one the 16-inch macbook pro we
knew that it was coming to the smaller
one in fact that was the whole theme the
whole title of my review of the bigger
laptop was now do it to the smaller one
so now they have well
mostly
this is a truly very minor revision it's
like a a spec bump that in most years
wouldn't make news
but it does this year so let's get into
it let's show what's exactly new and why
i care about this laptop that's been my
go-to for so long so number one most
importantly the butterfly keyboard from
the 16-inch macbook pro is now in this
refresh as well goodbye butterfly
switches you won't be missed welcome
back dedicated escape button welcome
back inverted t arrow keys and welcome
back real key travel you get that
millimeter of key travel and you've
heard me say before this is already so
much of a better typing experience a
better keyboard in the long run and then
internally it's a spec bump so it's up
to the newest 10th gen intel chips
quad-core across the board all the way
up to a quad-core i7 if you want one and
that also comes with iris graphics
improvements still not a dedicated gpu
option in this 13-inch laptop but at
least these new ios graphics are more
powerful
they're good enough now to drive a pro
display xdr if you wanted to so they are
improved and then there's also double
the starting storage it now starts at
512 gigs and goes all the way up to 4
terabytes which is sick so it's it's
always nice to have a lot of fast
internal storage and that's exactly what
this is and then baseline 16 gigs of
faster
lpddr4x ram now you can go up to 32 gigs
it's all a pretty nice spec bump here
but wait a minute
wait a minute
there's actually kind of two versions of
this new 13-inch macbook pro there's the
high-end one
and there's the baseline ones so all
these new specs that i've been giving
you the new intel chips the new higher
end base storage the new faster ram all
this stuff
only applies
to the higher end new 13-inch macbook
pros
the lower end doesn't get any of them so
if you look at apple's site you can see
the breakdown the baseline ones still
have the 8th gen intel chips they still
start at 8 gigs of slower lpddr3 ram
there's just 256 gigs of storage and
they also only have two thunderbolt 3
ports instead of all four so basically
these baseline configs that they're
selling are essentially the last year
13-inch macbook pro just with the new
keyboard and that's why i said at the
beginning the the keyboard is the number
one new thing because across the board
they all get the new keyboard which is
great um but for people who care about
performance
that's going to cost more now as dave 2d
so eloquently mentions in his video the
likely reason apple went with these 8th
gen intel chips for the baseline configs
is cost meaning the difference in
performance between a low end 8th gen
chip and a low end 10th gen chip
is pretty small but the cost difference
is 100 bucks plus so basically for
people who are buying these baseline
versions who presumably don't care as
much about performance as cost
this will be an okay trade-off for them
to save that money
i'll leave the full link to dave's video
below of course this review unit that
i've been using from apple
is a high-end one it's one of the
highest ones actually it's a quad core
i7
32 gigs of ram and two terabytes of
storage and it's about as ideal for me
as possible like i said the 13-inch
macbook pro is my go-to and this is the
highest and 13-inch
but it's also 3 000
and so for that price i think a lot of
people will start to care more about
performance which then brings in the
much bigger much more powerful 16-inch
macbook pro into the mix and that gets
you a much better thermal design a
dedicated gpu which is important and an
8 core core i9 for roughly the same
price that's a huge difference so it
leaves this 13-inch macbook pro the way
it's priced and just the way it sits in
the lineup in a sort of an awkward
middle child spot again
you know if people care more about
performance and they're willing to spend
more on that well the 16-inch macbook
pro sits right on the other side of that
just spend a little more and get that
way more performance
or if people are going for the baseline
because they want to save a little money
they don't care as much about
performance they want a lower price
well then the macbook air sits right on
the other side where you can save even
more money and not have that macbook pro
performance so either way you heard all
the new specs and the internals and how
much you're able to take advantage of
them really depends on things like your
workflow and the apps you're already
using you already know they have to be
well optimized but the rest of this
laptop is the same as we've known for so
long same design although technically it
is about one millimeter thicker to
accommodate this new keyboard so worth
it but yeah touch bar is still here the
huge trackpad is still here
same battery life and yep same quality
720p webcam as the past couple years of
apple laptops
now the the speakers and microphone have
also improved to the same level as a
16-inch macbook pro uh the microphone
you're hearing right now
sounds pretty good in this empty room
still a bit of echo but that's that's my
fault and the speakers you know it's not
as big of a laptop but for a laptop of
this size
best-in-class speakers again which is
awesome but yeah
the company that makes the best
smartphone cameras in the world
still makes this and
this 13-inch screen with uh
reasonable but still kind of thick
looking bezels
is still here you know a lot of people
were expecting including me a 14 inch
macbook pro the same way they bumped up
by one inch the size of the larger
macbook pro so
is it reasonable to still expect that
they might do that in the future
i don't really know anymore i want to
hope for it but i don't necessarily
think so so this is
a small update i think is what we're
getting at here but don't get me wrong
small updates are still a good thing we
need small updates i'm with renee
ritchie when he mentions that frequent
minor updates and spec bumps to just
keep things running up to date
are a good thing i would love to see an
imac update right now i would love to
see a mac mini update i'd love to see
more frequent minor updates just to keep
things up to date i would rather not
have to tell people don't buy a macbook
pro for five months because we know the
new keyboard is going to get updated
eventually but since we clearly don't
get those regular smaller updates from
apple the updates that we do get are a
bigger deal and we pay more attention to
them so this laptop this is the perfect
laptop for like my use case where i know
exactly what i want i don't want to
carry a bigger 16-inch macbook pro but i
still want more performance for things
like photo editing and occasional work
that the macbook air can't quite keep up
with
like this is ideal but of course it's
always worth noting and i have reviewed
the bigger more powerful 16-inch macbook
pro and the sort of default apple laptop
for starting out the macbook air i'll
leave them both below the like button
and now it's just sort of a question of
are we still expecting a 14-inch macbook
pro or a or maybe an arm macbook or
something like that in the next year so
the rumors point to yes wwdc is coming
up in a couple months maybe it won't be
that early but that's something to think
about so for me you know this is apple's
unit it's gone back to them i'm going to
continue using my 13-inch macbook air it
works fine but i'm just glad they
finally did this update that was long
overdue and i kind of wish apple was
more on time with more frequent updates
in general
that's about it
either way in case you're wondering the
merch is also now on sale permanently in
stock if you want to grab it link below
that's about it let me know what you
think if you get this or the macbook air
in the comment section below we'll hang
out thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace